[Music]
when people ask me what the whole
internal method is I like to describe it
as a mindfulness practice that's
disguised as a productivity system so
what sets bullet journal apart from
regular list keeping and journaling it's
not linear so essentially you create
these things called collections which
are essentially lists or graphs or
whatever you need of related information
so that could be a shopping list it
could be a to-do list it could be a
project it could be a fertility tracker
whatever you need it to be and bullet
journal lays a framework for you to have
all these different components work with
each other and the way it does that is
through simple mechanisms you already
know page numbers page titles so for
example there's an index and the index
allows you to simply store all the
different collections that you have in
your notebook so you can quickly find
them again there are four core
collections in the bullet journal one is
the daily log it's a way for us to
capture all the thoughts that bubble up
throughout the day and categorize them
into tasks events and notes using
different symbols so we keep our entries
very short and then we also tag them
essentially with an icon then we have
this thing known as a monthly log and
the monthly log on one page is a monthly
calendar and then on the next page is a
monthly tasks list essentially where you
can create a monthly inventory each
month you take a step back think about
what you want to get done that month
anything that's bubbled up and getting
it out of your head and on paper the
calendar on the monthly log can be used
in one of two ways in a traditional way
but I prefer to use it as a way to
actually write down things after they
happen so the calendar quickly becomes a
timeline of the decisions you made and
the events that have happened
essentially and having the context of
when what actually happened can be very
revealing in its own right like did you
actually start working out three weeks
ago or a week and a half ago did you
send that email then or what not so it's
a timeline of highlights in your life so
you have the monthly log then you have
the future log for
the things that happen outside of the
current month the bullet journal unfolds
in real time so we don't hoard pages
essentially every time you flip a page
it can accept pretty much anything that
you needed to be it drawings poetry
lists projects whatever you want and the
way that works is with the index so
every time you flip the page and you use
it for a different purpose you number
your pages and then you list that page
and it's title in the index so you have
these four core collections but you can
create collections for pretty much
anything you like
again shopping lists vacation planning
lists can be infinite pretty much you
can keep writing things down and whether
or not you do them well you know that
just depends on the person what I found
really important is that I keep re
engaging with the things that I write
down and keep curating the substance of
my experience if you will so we have the
monthly log essentially every month we
set up a new monthly log and in between
the monthly logs you have the daily logs
and the daily logs are there to capture
your tasks events and notes so at the
end of every month you reflect through
the past month and see the things that
you've done and the things that you
haven't done and then you have a choice
to make if something isn't done you can
ask yourself why is it because you just
didn't get around to it or because it's
not really adding value to your life is
it vital does it matter and if it
doesn't then you get rid of that item
but if it does then you have to take it
and transcribe it or as we say migrate
it into the next month and that way
nothing really slips through the cracks
in the process of reviewing your
previous month you're automatically
filtering out distractions from your
life so it's not about keeping a
never-ending to-do list it's about
keeping a to-do list that's actionable
with things on it that you believe
actually add value to your life and
that's something I haven't seen before
so a lot of people ask me like doesn't
it take a lot of time to keep rewriting
your tasks and I would say
it might take a little bit more time
upfront but if it's not even worth
rewriting then is it really worth taking
up space in your life in your mind in
your day because a lot of times the
things that we work on will absorb so
much more time than they need to I think
the question is does it need to be done
in the first place
[Music]